good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the Friday app clinic this week after
enduring Ian's constant switches to
himself on producer cam we've decided to
make life a little easier and just have
him on the show so welcome to the app
clinic in thank you very much I'm also
joining just because I this week's topic
is podcast players and I am an
inveterate Atlas podcast listener I
really enjoy podcasts although I've also
because of the let's just say the
characteristics of the apps that we're
looking at or this week and just how I
feel about them I also brought my friend
big Pete and anytime I get so frustrated
that I just want to drive my phone
through my head because the podcast
player UI is so bad I'll be taking music
I so expect the aim to be pretty drunk
by the end of today's episode that is a
spoiler a lot so I like lucky and said
where I really look at podcast apps
today we've got a wide variety of apps
to choose from I think we have something
like 8 8 or 9 apps that were nominated
in the moderator queue this week or
there were four more than that just
wrote a line somewhere I think we popped
out somewhere around the eight or nine
marks so that's that's as far as we're
going to try and go twelve do get that
12 but you guys need is Mazie like and I
think we're gonna get through twelve
Daniel make title cards for 12 that's
thanks guys
we've also got something that Daniel
who's doing the engineering for us today
we've got app clinic veteran Fred Chung
who's going to be helping us out as a
producer so if you have any questions
comments anything that you want to pass
on to us during the show please let us
know in the in the comment stream for
the G+ event and Fred will pass those
along to us now let's switch to the
producer cam shall we
Frank you're up there Kim
excellent and you even got the shocked
and surprised producer on camera look
down perfect excellent
oh and so let's I know we've got some
we're up to 12 absolute death today so
let's let's kick off let's get started
right so just to write to get started
here let's let's talk about what a
podcast planner should do right well
absolutely what do we use podcast
players for well I mean really I like to
think of podcast players is basically
being an music players except instead of
music it's all spoken word and my idea
of kind of the perfect version of the
media of the music player is something
which is gonna let you listen to both
your own music and the radio
switching between them well I don't
think that maybe you play quite exists
yet so that's another wish list for you
guys but for podcast that should be
possible right podcast elicitation
now let me just add something because I
won I'm gonna take this up one level
let's not talk about just the features
let's talk about how we use it and for
me it's in the car okay indeed I think
that's probably the newspaper podcast
place is going to be people who are
commuting whether it's in your car or or
in the train and we're in California
here so I've had to get used to driving
to working it I think the for me anytime
that I have the ability to sit down and
read something I would much rather read
it so the only time I want a podcast is
when I have to keep my eyes on something
else like the road oh right yeah it's
generally considered helpful with that
in mind I've noticed the great many of
the podcast players who just don't
actually work very well in the car
that's an interesting point
all right let's let's take a look for
another level and say well what is a
podcast app what is it that that you'd
really like to see which would cause you
not to drink because frankly if podcasts
apps make you drink and you like to use
podcast players while you're driving
this is not a good message believe me
the California Department of
Transportation has acts
very clear with me on that point I'm not
surprised
so well so why don't we take a look at
that list please yeah can you put that
with that list of parts Danielle yes
notice that angry baby wants very much
for podcast players to fit into these
particular what would you call them
recommendations yeah absolutely best
practices for all it's a wish list right
it's it's an available wish list for
podcast apps absolutely
we put angry baby up there because
that's kind of how I felt no they're
looking at 12 of these this morning um
there are some good ones there actually
are some absolutely some very Google's I
don't think we found a perfect one no I
don't think if you took all the best
things from each of these you'd have a
pretty kick-ass app so I think that's
hopefully what we'll get to by the end
of this is to encourage each of the
developers here to build apps which make
all of them awesome but notice that part
of what makes a great podcast is just
what makes a great synchronized app in
general anything that you're bringing
information from the Internet to the
users device that should be as
transparent as possible Rachel had a
great talk at Google I know about making
apps magical and making it feel like
you're always connected to this
wonderful well of information at very
high speeds even though we know that
even a very fast mobile connection isn't
always a hundred percent reliable or
speedy so the first thing that a podcast
player needs to do is make sure that it
has good synchronization something
that's doing is apparently background
something that the user doesn't have to
worry about or futz with and I think
that some of these podcast apps side and
did a reasonably good job of that others
maybe not so much why don't we take a
look at some of the first ones here
let's say for instance dog catcher catch
is a really popular one so I've asked
people a few times because we we
actually have a podcast of our Android
developer live office hours which we put
out there and we actually
all of the Google i/o sessions as
podcasts as well and so I asked people
you know what what are the podcast apps
that you commend and doggcatcher was
definitely amongst the the very top so
this is this isn't that but a lot of
people like can we uh we get the tablet
on screen as well they're perfect
so doc Richard starts out with a quick
set of configuration options and I'm
fine with this okay finite I want I want
to keep a couple episodes of each
podcast all right I guess I'd better
accept the EULA hopefully it doesn't
commit me to anything too terrible and
then it shows feeds playing audio video
news mm-hmm so I I somewhat like that
okay yes well you got a nice tablet you
want for your tablets tones I'm gonna go
ahead and click on something and play it
well now that's interesting
you just told me no episode is loaded
and playlist is empty well obviously I
just clicked on this right absolutely
now I do like one thing about dog
catcher is what's what's the most
obvious set of controls on this what is
the thing that catches your eye more
than anything else I would like to say
that it's the end of what it's such a
button is long one I agree with you
completely it would it surprise you to
know that many podcast apps not easy to
access well having just looked to 12 no
wouldn't surprise me but it may surprise
some of you one of the things that you
should probably think about when you
design a user interface is what will
your users spend the most time doing and
if your application is listening to
podcasts you might think that listening
would be one of the things that you want
to have front and center but some of
these apps don't have transport buttons
readily accessible some of them are too
small some of the move all over the
screen and I found at least one where it
was hidden away in a context a context
menu to be able to play interesting yeah
very interesting of context menus we've
got a bunch on here I don't know
what do these do let's let's find oh wow
what doesn't it there's a lot of context
there now I guess the the question I
have here is if I have expressed some
interest in a podcast and even the point
of maybe wanting to play that why isn't
it
downloading that podcast right now
absolutely what I have to ask it to
download indeed and I think that's it's
a kind of a key feature here with you
know there's two things that that Ian's
mentioned which I really I think it's a
theme across a lot of these and and one
is that this UI is really busy there is
a huge amount of information to try and
consume here to understand you know what
you're supposed to do next and so it
takes you a really long time to go from
clicking the app launcher to being able
to use the app for the purpose which it
was specifically designed now let's talk
about on that on that base let's talk
about my very least favorite part of
this from UI it's a button you see all
the time and it needs to die but before
we talk about this button let me take a
drink in spike is causing us problems
all right all right then if any one how
bad it is then maybe people at I'm
fostering a pizza so yeah this is a
little better how's this all right yeah
Fred's on a time delay right in 15
seconds he'll tell you whether or not
you're annoying yes well let's just get
you you can tell by the way that I'm
usually a lot more lubricated when we do
the game show as time goes by I stumble
over my words less and less it's the
power of alcohol mmm can you guess what
button I'm talking about right oh uh
well gosh if I had to choose a button it
would be it would be this button here
that that's a bad button that is a bad
button but you don't see that in
everything even less favored I have a
button that needs to die a thousand
horrible deaths actually I would say
about maybe fifteen thousand because I
bet that's how many apps use this button
that's a lot
laughs oh gosh I mean for a podcast app
I kind of want to see these buttons
bingo
thank you very much rate oh that is the
correct answer I'll be getting your
prize later why in god's name would you
have a synchronized button when you have
the ability to stay in sync all the time
absolutely don't ask me to refresh it
just refresh be fresh these space is
really new there's really I think no
reason why you would ever want a refresh
button certainly not front and center
like that no absolutely it was a time
where I could see it as something maybe
in the overflow menu to force a refresh
but these days with things like Google
Cloud messaging you can do those
real-time pings you can have a server
which is checking these feeds and paying
your users directly when they have new
content it's in my mind this button is a
fix me cuz I screwed up button mmm mmm
for some reason things didn't
synchronize correctly or for some reason
I want to override my sync settings so
for instance one really useful feature
that a lot of these apps have is the
ability to not synchronize until you get
on Wi-Fi or until you're doing this
plugged in absolutely you let it sink
overnight or while it's sitting on your
desk at work or whatever and it doesn't
eat up your bandwidth while you're
driving the car I love that that's great
absolutely and if I need to override
that that's fine but this isn't one of
those times we're on Wi-Fi this tablet
is plug Malachi's I guess it's not
plugged in maybe that maybe you aren't
even still no I'm not being field so we
want to be able to you know I mean we're
gonna press this button and it is going
to start synchronizing things
there we go updating it's a lot of use
of toasts in this app as well to tell me
what's going on I have to tell you I
kind of think of toasts as it's the the
lagdi statement of a view I it's it's
I'm building an app I want to make sure
my services are running like running I
want to make sure that my errors are
visible when I'm testing the app users
should never see this but it's a printer
it's bugging when you don't have a
debugger attached the other thing that I
think is interesting is there is a
download manager here and I don't I I
think that's a good thing I always like
to know what's going on but notice that
I can't get to it until I'm
synchronizing oh yeah so now I can go
here and I see alright there's a
download queue what's interesting here
is you know I've got something that says
okay this is downloading and these will
download soon and I can cancel it what
happens if I click here what what sort
of context menu might it pop up
apparently nothing nothing interesting
in fact it turns out that this button
which to me says there's more stuff you
might want to click this because there's
stuff you could see well in the previous
menu there was like 400 things you think
sani clicked on it I'm thinking to
myself oh my god why don't I click that
I should probably click that okay
because I am missing something please
just okay now there you go that's
interesting because if I clicked it in
there in the right way it would bring me
this uh-huh but if I just click the
right next to it it's canceled I say
listen this is a really interesting
point could you show the the audience
the size of your finger put it next to a
Galaxy Nexus for some scale that's the
reason why we have 48 pixel touch
targets because when you try and get
that thumb on to that's why I'm gonna
have like Adrian Brody hands well
they're not oversized fingers you know
and that's the key there you've got man
hands and you should be proud of them
and the point is you can't hit those
touch targets and when you have a
destructive action within touch range of
another touch target and big enough
you're gonna get exactly the situation
that Ian's been facing where it's been
canceling downloads instead of getting
context so good in progress in fact that
that way a neighbor's time I've seen
that context menu of like ten downloads
exactly right did not even realize it
was there now what I do like is now now
that I'm in this I can
I can start playing things and if I
don't like what I'm playing I can skip
it and this is actually kind of a cool
feature interesting it will only respond
to long presses and that to me is a car
feature hmm show okay um now I worry a
little bit because what I really want to
do is plug this into you the Bluetooth
audio in my car so that I can use my
steering wheel controls show that resets
and I don't think it's elitist to say
that anymore
my mom's Hyundai has the steering wheel
controls show sure okay so so I'm gonna
go ahead and long press it and then it
will well what to do so it is not clear
yeah well a little right but the reason
I think the reason it did nothing is
because nothing is downloaded now of
course you've only got there the first
thing which you're playing has been
downloading else has right so I can I
can play this but this is actually one
of the things that really bothers me is
if you look at how this is set up this
is a feed management app front and
center I think you'd like to manage your
feeds now the truth is I don't want to
manage my feeds it reminds me of you
know going to a music app and having the
first thing it shows you be a store or a
metadata editor something like that a
lot of music apps do that for various
reasons but I hate it because nine times
out of ten what I really want to do when
I enter one of these apps is play the
contest listen to some content
absolutely it seems like playing the
content should be the absolute most
important thing and if you don't have
content to play the first thing you
should be doing is figuring out why
there's no content to play in fixing
that absolutely absolutely I mean this
is the key I mean for most of you use
cases here what you want to do is open
the app hit play you know with whatever
you were doing
drumming EECOM presumably and I have to
say it's the first thing in the morning
or when I'm on my way home and I listen
to music I just want to open the music
app hit play and be done with it
at the very most what you want to do is
maybe choose the style of what a
playlist or a theme and it's the same
here for these sorts of apps it's
exactly the same use case particular
thing I want listen to a particular
theme
if I hit skip because I'm bored
something I don't want to then have to
go through that management of the
streams again the idea that the first
thing I want to do is look at how my
streams are doing is an immediate clue
to me that this app can't manage its own
stuff when I open it now I was a dog
catcher user for a while and the reason
that I finally left it is because every
time I got into my car in the evening I
would start driving I would open up my
my phone and I realize that I have to
pull over the side of the road and
manage stuff Hey all right that was a
horrible experience what I really want
to be able to do is get directly to the
content and here's another point not
only am i stuck managing the feeds as my
central thing but look at the other
categories we've got playing and then
we've got so that makes sense
shall we now choke up to get to my what
what you're currently listening to
sure although I'm not even certain that
that's what we're currently listening to
but you know we can't actually play it
because of the man no audio go to an ear
back excellent wow that was quick nice
if that happened thanks thanks Fred Wow
did you did you fix it by unmuting your
headset okay I'm just asking excellent
all right so the the other things we can
look at here is we've got audio podcasts
okay that's that's somewhat useful I
mean there's definitely a difference
between audio and video like you
wouldn't want to listen to what we're
doing right now in the car no be
particularly useful references to the
stuff happening on screen right the
benefit and you would not get the
benefit of our faces which are so so
pretty so there are pluses and minuses
in the news now that's that's an
interesting choice right Wow as a
top-level tab destination that's
interesting now let's
as for this with something that is more
let's say entertainment oriented so um
google music for instance I'm not gonna
say that Google music is the best UI
ever
but what um what Google music does is
very very common right all now see we're
talking about yes I don't want to add
account select ah theoretically so we
could talk for hours about Google music
but what I really wanted to show is how
Google Music has this feature that every
music app that I've used actually
recently has which is that you can
browse by and put things together by
albums artists songs playlist and genres
absolutely and recent and of course
there's an ale playing feature as well
it seems to me and I may be jumping on
your cue here but these seem like
reasons and navigation cues completely I
mean they're they're so common and so
well-known it's not just Google music
that does this my stereo in the car does
absolutely
my mom's Hyundai does it actually so I'm
just got a pretty sweet Hyundai
it's amazing else they've got some good
products they're not that I'd ever drive
one no why because cuz I work for Google
and I have appearances and they bring
out like a a hybrid electric yeah so
let's go back to dark attach it yeah um
the truth is I happy to know what my
audio stuff is don't care about my video
waves that I've got news but what I
really want is to have a page that says
news comedy sports science you know the
genres that I actually listen to you I
think this is a really important point
because I think with with podcasting
apps like this podcast there's this
temptation to develop for yourself
which is it's a good place to start but
if you want to have real wide-scale
appeal then you need to think a little
bit beyond that so think about how
someone who does
actually use listen to podcasts who
isn't specifically looking for a podcast
player but they do want to spoken audio
content someone who would be listening
to the radio but they realize the radio
is you know not working for them there's
only NPR once they listen to all of
those what's what's next and so if you
approach this the same way you johner is
you have albums playlists all these and
they can be much more familiar with you
could listen to some political
commentary so you go to that and you see
all of these different shows not feeds
or anything like that but shows which
have the kind of content rights here and
I wanted you know for instance sometimes
in the morning I really want to listen
to news no matter where it's coming from
I get like you know five minutes of the
BBC in the morning and then I get my CNN
whatever I also want to be able to skip
you know maybe I'm you know the BBC is
talking about sub-saharan Africa today
and you know not interesting to me so
I'm gonna skip over to whatever in the
evening get in my car I want to listen
to comedy I want to listen to you know
smartest man in the world or radio 4
comedy of the week absolutely so I want
to be able to pick that job skip around
inside of it without having to skip over
all of the other genres that I have on
the phone absolutely yeah let's say it I
think that that's one thing that all of
these podcasts are unlocking to a
certain extent yeah hey help with the
discovery cuz I think that's a lot of
what the solutions that I've been seeing
is apps which help you manage existing
collection of podcasts so you already
know what you want you've already got
them subscribed in Google Reader or
something similar
and that's why you have this management
becomes a really big portion of it
because it's all about managing feeds
you already have you can create
something much more powerful by having
aiding that discovery it's like well I
know that I want to listen to you know
comedy in the evening so give me a bunch
of comedy content make that easier for
me
I think somebody that does it actually
pretty well is stitcher which I don't
see on here so may not have picked it up
there their entire deal is about
discovery they also do streaming so you
don't have to worry about downloads at
all nothing
management is - they are that's almost
Pandora like you interface recovery the
only problem with stitcher is once
you've got something set up it's very
very confusing and how to change it I
think they use like a star favorites
right but then you have to start
something and then do some extra stuff
you gotta check some boxes so I would we
won't bring up stitcher right now
because we all have it installed it
wasn't one of the top apps that we were
looking at on the moderator what I
wanted to call it out it's something it
does discovery a little better
now so one of the things that isn't
quite as good that discovery
yes they leave it on the test
sure oh you forgot that most important I
did the magic rule all right leave you
microwave can see I think we're done
with dog catcher and we're gonna move on
now but yes we are aware that we have
spent a fair amount of time we have
spent a long time talking about podcast
apps in general yes exactly yeah if we
were just gonna like Gong ourselves
after five minutes then the audience
would have missed the amazing
transitions and handoffs that you and I
have obviously spent weeks practically
clearly well rehearsed so let's take a
look at help me out here vote some chaga
no that's not quite right I missed an in
Volks some fungi yeah there you go yeah
I knew that the foreigner would be able
together um so again very first thing
you see there not a lot of white space
and yeah and it kind of has the the
podcast icon of shame indeed so and okay
I have no subscriptions well let's you
know let's get a subscription fine okay
yeah this is a problem yeah I I realize
I'm shallow I realize I'm not a good
techie but the truth is there's a lot of
apps that don't make me type into our I
haven't memorized the URLs for all of
your favorite pie is not
you'd think that I would have em on and
certainly I mean Android has it much
better
cut and paste functionality than it used
to do so that's what yeah I mean you can
have to take doing it this makes me need
to take it
well I ensuing that I will type in the
one podcast that I know if you want the
truth is I and probably most of the
people that have already hun enclose it
yeah they'll oppose live podcast now you
can see from this this is actually a
pretty easy to remember URL but it's
taken me more time to type this in then
I really have patience for and if I've
misspelled this and then it's kind of
game over pretty much screwed yeah so
I've put it in it still says we have no
subscriptions yeah I can look through
here and everything is empty now we have
a spinning the the spinning program so
we need something look what's happening
how exciting we have something in there
I would successfully subscribe to the
podcast I wouldn't have minded seeing
some sort of progress indication while
waiting for that yeah you want to move
already subscribed show us show us that
what we subscribe to so that if we're
going through like with fingers of
lightning typing in all the row you
memorize URLs we at least know what
we're up to
we can click through and otherwise it's
that's pretty it's a it's a nice simple
UI so this is something I wanted to
highlight for this app in particular
it's compared to some of the others
we're going to look at has a very clean
UI it's very simple very straightforward
just showing the information that you
need though arguably not enough
information now this is where it all
gets a little bit weird
first up if you keep your eye on this
section of the screen you'll see that
there is a checkbox which occasionally
flashes in or out I'm not entirely sure
why or how to bring it up consistently
but see that just for a fraction of a
second no I did what
no no not that time but again so okay so
we've got this big amount of white
screen and we have a play button but
it's it's not that it's hidden but it's
not particularly
it doesn't really jump out so if I was
gonna try and use this app in my car
I've got a problem right away
now I think that you know we can't we
got a bathroom - Harvey's obviously
there thinking well I've got an action
that I want to take show me to put on
the action bar and this is a good
example of when it's okay to break the
rules there are actions that you're
taking on content where the content in
the screen is the most important thing
and those actions are far and away best
suited to the action bar absolutely
however there are some actions that are
either extremely contextual so you put
them next to the content directly next
to the content or so Universal that they
really don't belong in the action bar
because there they are themselves the
most important thing and in this case I
would argue that the transport for any
app that plays audio the transport is
the most important thing absolutely in
fact it should be on every screen you
never want to be in a position where you
can't access the transport because if
nothing else you might need to pause
that audio exactly and this is a good
example so again and this is the theme
that I'm going to continue to come back
to time and time again which is I want
the app to start and doing what I
downloaded it for as quickly as possible
ideally as soon as I click the icon open
the app it will start doing something in
this case playing me some kind of audio
here I've had to click I've had to add a
subscription then navigate into that and
then navigate into a particular thing
and then hit play before it's actually
going to start that playback at which
point it does introduce the controls
along the bottom which is nice they are
absolutely tiny yeah which makes me
think well I was gonna say it makes me
think this was designed for a fine but
we have the tab the tablet layout with
fragments so they're halfway there
and I get the impression I think this is
even an alpha release so it's it's early
days know them but you definitely want
to consider straightaway as Ian just
pointed out these need to be big buttons
they need to be front and center this is
the key to what your app is doing
so to increase their size while we're
talking about the transport mechanism
because I think this is a good point and
I want to talk a little bit more about
that if if we switch to the to the
camera phone or the phone camera I
should say then would you be able to
look at some of these apps on a phone
and I'd I'm going to do that because I
want to highlight a couple of specific
things so if I start playing an app here
in dog catcher there's a few things I'm
going to look for straightaway so as
soon as I navigate away from that app I
still want to be able to control that
meet that audio from anywhere so the
first thing I'm going to check is to see
whether or not I can control it on the
lockscreen which I can which is nice we
even have the album art which is tidy
had the ability to pause play skip hello
again skip doesn't actually do anything
in this no it does it does straight it
is tricky it's like I want to be able to
skip this so I'm getting bored and
listen to either the next the next
podcast in that particular album or skip
to a completely different podcast if you
know if that's the better option it
makes sense so let's let's unlock this I
also want to be able to do that in the
notifications and again this is
something that the dog catcher is done
well so I can actually pause directly
from the notification now you'll note
that by doing so they've actually
removed the notifications straightaway
right which is a little weird it is a
little weird now this is kind of tricky
right because the reason the
notification is there when it's playing
is because you need an ongoing
notification if you have a service
running and when I've paused at that
service isn't running so let's take it
away thing is give me a chance here you
know maybe I just pause it because you
know I want to yell at someone out the
window you cut me off
and I want to be able to press play
again straight away and you'll note that
it's it's gone from everywhere so if I
go back to the lock screen again there's
no way to restart the audio until I
reopen the app and so yes so what is it
was a abort abort abort exactly it's a
big red button and that's too aggressive
well this would be great if they use
jellybean rich notifications because
then they gave you that choice I mean
maybe you did just want to kill the
whole thing absolutely clicked on that
notification that didn't have any
indication of what it was going to do at
all exactly but if you didn't
in general we suggest that when you make
a notification if it doesn't have any
you I if it doesn't have a rich UI
associated with it the natural thing is
when you click on it you should bring up
the activity this that's firing the
notification to begin with
absolutely and that should always be
your default you shouldn't do anything
else really unless you have like we said
rich notification UI on jellybean let's
just have a quick look if if dog catcher
has a widget and it does and so the last
thing in it that's cool they've done a
good job there so they have maintained
those transport mechanisms throughout
every part of the of the UI of the
system UI so that's that's definitely a
thumbs up for dog catcher not all of the
apps that we looked at do any of those
little and all of them next one should
we have a look at at another app
absolutely why don't we go ahead and go
to beyond pod which is another one that
gets a lot of good rec absolutely not it
it turns out that this is has been one
of my go-to what apps although probably
because it's the least frustrating of
all the frustrations I've encountered
okay high price well sitting that in
that high bar yeah yeah so this is a an
interesting UI it goes from feed to
player there should also be let's see
yeah
you'd say you've got a categorized list
it turns out actually they think the
developers are very responsive this is
actually a different UI than I used you
know just last week they used this so
they've done categorization in here
which is cool but again a little weird
hmm and difficult to use in the car yes
very absolutely this is a good example
where you want to have a big UI with big
big buttons that you can just press
which have pictures which indicate what
they are so you don't need to think or
read or navigate or worry about touching
the wrong bit it's just bang-bang-bang
indeed now I have to compliment these
guys on doing a much better job then the
first version of beyond pod that I
downloaded where the initial set of
categories
was on a viewpager hmm and the second
page was the detail of whatever category
I say the third page was a detail of the
feed had selected and then the fourth
page was I think they're now playing and
paging between the viewpager did all
sorts of really wacky things so they're
very very it was a departure from what
you would expect if you pay yeah you
don't want the view paid you to ever
maintain any sort of state apart from
where you've scrolled to on it on in any
particular ListView yeah so let's let's
go ahead and start now this is um this
is one thing that's a little interesting
they they do RSS as well as actual audio
so so this is an RSS feed let's let's
see if we can find one that's actually
an audio let's know the baby saying yeah
so this now this is interesting the they
do streaming which is really really nice
but I will say the one thing that's been
extremely frustrating to me about using
beyond pot is that we we try to stream
but we don't always have a connection
and the on pod if you don't have a good
connection will download it will play
downloaded stuff but it will try to
phone home first so there are cases
where I have completely downloaded a
podcast but because the player can't
make a connection it won't play that's
very frustrating that's the same sort of
rage inducing anger that you get when
you want to play a game which you've
paid the license for you've played it
before it totally works but because you
happen to be on an airplane going to
play Angry Birds or asphalt 7 for a few
hours in between here and Honolulu you
can't because you can't get a Wi-Fi
connection exactly
it's also worth pointing out here as
well when you're doing a buffering and
streaming in general it's it is a good
it is a good technique but you need to
also be careful to be doing it the right
way to make sure that you're not
draining the battery just for the sake
of having these sorts of downloads and
so one of the best practices which we
try and point out is that you should
have enough content for the foreseeable
future use of this app and so if you're
listening to things like podcasts you
probably want to pre buffer the entire
episode
you may even want to think about getting
whatever's next on the queue as well so
they don't just happen to be there's a
set of lights on Charleston which is in
a cell tower dead zone so if I happen to
get to that stop and it's it's a long
intersection you're there for a few
minutes if I get there and a song stops
you know I run out of song depending on
the app I'm using I'm screwed it's
sitting there going oh get to it
eventually and it's not until I'm you
know I'm on the freeway then like it I
don't you have a strategy for dealing
with that not just buffering up what you
think you're gonna need maybe falling
back to something old or whatever that's
blew it now this what you're seeing on
the screen now is my face but if you
were seeing the tablet there you go the
this is my other pet peeve um and this
is not limited to be on par there's
actually a few other players that do
this I tried to skip forward and it says
the playlist is empty now it's
interesting because I got to this by
going to the BBC and choosing the first
episode absolutely if I skip forward
after that it based on your extensive
knowledge of iPods or you know Sony
Walkman or its music players of any
stripe what would you expect to happen
at that point I kind of expect them to
play the next episode right yeah yeah
that's that that is also what I expected
however no it will not play that because
I don't have anything the playlist now
the interesting thing is having been a
be on pod customer for about six months
now Bobby on prod Pro I have absolutely
no idea how to add anything to the
playlist I have no clue that's how angry
he exactly he's ripping the mic off he's
labelled angry what's even worse is that
I now they don't sing it here so maybe
they've changed it but a the version I
originally used called it the smart
playlist which implied that it had some
sort of intelligence it might do
something for me to apparently I'll say
does it imply that anal I that you need
to be smart to use the playlist I think
what it's saying is it's just smart
enough
know that it doesn't need to listen to
the sofa where playlist will not serve
I'd like to go to the next master I'm
sorry I can't do that in exactly so to
uh to wrap up a bit some of the other
things that we looked at include good
news which has some really nice features
but suffers from many of the same
feedback problems find about in
particular it's possible to get good
news into a state where you have to just
sit there staring at a screen waiting
for it to do something and it is giving
you very little idea of what it's doing
especially I this is especially
frustrating because I have let's say
2500 unread articles in my Google Reader
account which good credit links up with
very very easily it will say I've synced
100 articles I can't read those articles
I can't see them all I can see is the
thing that says you gotta wait and get a
2500 so you might you might think about
whether or not that's a good user
experience listen up is promising a
little rough yeah that's definitely made
no impression on me whatsoever you know
stay cast leave an impression terrible
icon I it looks fine on this screen
because it's against this kind of cloudy
background so against anything else the
problem is it just doesn't have enough
contrast so it's very very easy to get
to blend in the background so why don't
we finish up by just taking a look at
pocket casts which for all its sins is
probably one of the the best that we've
looked at this this probably going to be
my this is gonna be a podcast is it
gonna be a go to podcast app on a tablet
I have no idea haven't used it on a
tablet wouldn't use it on a tablet yeah
I don't carry that around in my well I
think contemplating this because I have
a spare nexus 7 that's right you're all
jealous and I've been trying to figure
it out how I can mount it to the
dashboard of my Prius because I work for
Google so I have a Prius but all of the
surfaces in yours operable
well this is true I went to the
dealership I'm like I need a car and
then you know after 10 minutes of
talking to me they knew exactly what
they needed to give me all the surfaces
the surfaces on the inside are exactly
the same as the surfaces on the outside
so there's nothing flat
everything is curved and rounded so
there's nowhere I can stick the device
to actually to mount it in my car so I
don't know but that would be an instance
of if you have a car with slightly
square edges I have the impression that
many American cars have quite straight
edges inside the car
oh no that's a that's a myth perfed
emitted by europeans political
establishment I see I love the man is
white let me have you know straight
surfaces in the car then I guess it's a
non-issue but I always thought that
would be quite quite useful so this is
something that we never like to see yeah
hi there it's like in the Hitchhiker's
Guide where it says I'm gonna press this
button Oh what did do I sign lit up
saying please do not press this button
again all this is saying is yeah by the
way don't press that button yeah not yet
in the press do something else
press a different button I I think this
is a programmer thing right because you
like oh yeah did you mean to put a
semicolon there yeah and what a new
programmers always say well it knows
that I need it I don't why did that
that's a semicolon eed to tell me it's
not there right you should be more
magical than C++ that's all I'm saying
so if we wanted to have a podcast I
guess we we click on the library icon
and this is the really frustrating thing
is once I've clicked on the library icon
absolutely nothing happens it's pretty
much a it's a pretty big like Lena mr.
headphone icon is full of I'm taking you
taking a drink I think what we actually
have to do is do a surge oh and this is
nice so we got some popular podcasts
that's good a browse category I mean
that the discoverability here is much
much yeah this is my most you know Roman
Nurik would go ballistic yeah thank you
he's gone so angry that he's fallen off
the Hangout that's that out of media and
off the internet yep now we're out of
time that's true
but we're gonna keep going anyway that's
so many people were interrupting is you
the reason that Roman Nurik would be mad
about this just drinking mad yeah which
doesn't take much cuz he's Russian but
Ukrainian I think I think you made a
mistake the huge faux pas yeah I am so
sorry
alright I'm not gonna point out who is
apologizing to here's it could be the
Russians could be the Ukrainians it
could be Roman it could be anyone
Frank's were really just Roman and
everyone else and everyone else Roman so
and everyone re uh well no I'm
apologizing to everyone except the
person who put this god-awful ribbon on
this list it's actually reminds me of a
demo'd you remember the demo scene from
like I guess it was the late 90s we had
like a 64 K demo where you'd have like
awesome graphic stuff done within 64 K
and one of the cool things you can do
was these gradients and they would shift
and changed and move not in the 90s
anymore that's quite true now if we
worried he would be milli and I would be
vanilla and we're not yeah
and here gonna be thankful for that the
other thing that we object to or that
Roman objects to you I I don't know this
is just running yeah is these uh there's
a little right arrows oh the bright
carrots yeah I'm not a fan of those at
all yeah no nobody is
oh and particularly when they get
stretched in this way that's no that's
oh that's that's a beautiful beautiful
thing okay well let's not be too harsh
let's just choose something the Sesame
Street podcast I mean it wait that's got
to be completely well that that doesn't
put you in a good mood well I'll just
hit the back button here nice that
worked mom just
oh no you're out also I should point out
that you hitting the back button the
fact that that worked is nice but the
fact that there's no other way to
navigate back from that deep nested
thing to the bit where you get to play
it's kind of irritating well yeah in the
sense that I if I had a real action bar
with navigational hints I would be able
to navigate directly rather than hitting
a button five times exactly
but speaking of hitting that button you
know if I if I go here and start one of
these things going and then press this
little magic button
it's going to show me this and
and now I don't know if it'll do this on
the tablet but on the phone hitting the
back button on that just quit the
absinthe yeah yeah it doesn't do that on
the tablets that's cool they have kind
of a nice UI where this skips forward 30
seconds this skips back 10 seconds I see
that the it's actually a video cost
because we can see that's being
displayed oh and which is a good thing
to point out because it means they can't
see the rest of what you're doing right
now but so we're gonna have to do just
just one more one more depth into this
one of these needs to be okay
Greg Proops never has video so we'll go
ahead and use Greg Proops hit the back
button a few times several times I don't
mind I'm a back button hitter maybe one
one too many times so we'll go to the
smartest man in the world podcast notice
it's it's going to play immediately well
wonderful well it may be it once it's
off cards yeah okay now you can see this
so on the right hand side of the screen
30-second skip forward I really like
left hand side 10 seconds back that's
awesome what did he just now if I click
here what's he gonna do oh it's just
actually skipping forward why would they
need that this is skipping forward no
wait this whole side of the screen was
skipping forward absolutely what I
really want when I get this is to go to
the next pod but next track yeah there's
no way to go to the next track which
again always mean no end because
sometimes I just get a podcast that's
really boring so if this was a podcast
this may be the time we'd want to skip
ahead
wouldn't you be saying to yourself god I
wish I could just press a button and
skip directly to the Friday review
exactly I've skipped 30 seconds 15 20
times now I'm just done I want to get to
the good stuff
by the way rachel is not talking about a
podcast player he's talking about his
life and he doesn't win drugs anyway um
so to sum up pocket casts is a great app
functionally the UI does not look like
it's designed for Android it looks like
it you know a I think it
took some cues from maybe a different
system one that's a little more bubbly
and rounded than ours a little bit like
and that shows up in the reviews you
know absolutely about that it's the same
way you know if you if you bought that
other phone and you got an app that
looked just like an Android app you'd
probably absolutely you've been
similarly frustrated it's that it's
creating that magic you want to open the
app and feel like you're at home feel
like it's part of the ecosystem part of
the system that you're running you open
this app and straightaway you are
wondering what phone you have how does
this work how do I get to do different
things how do i navigate all of those
things which as a developer who maybe
owns a different kind of phone it's
obvious to you I know how this how this
works you tab across the top here and
refresh icon is always here but for
typical Android users it's gonna be
hostile it's a hostile environment and
that's what you want to avoid but at
least I can arrange my podcasts in
episode and look at everything without
having to delve through multiple
categories but of all the things that
we've looked at today we haven't seen
anything that does podcast playing
nearly as as well as just a simple music
player absolutely and it's interesting
that you know when I've asked people
about their favorite podcast player one
of the most frequent responses I get is
people asking I really wish Google music
just integrated podcasts and I think
that's an opportunity for people because
Google music the player is not a
particularly fancy implementation it's
trying it straight up right it's just
Suzanne white bread it is totally white
bread and a lot of these apps we haven't
we haven't delved into the details of
what a lot of these apps do because they
do a lot of things they have a lot of
functionality that's really great and
really important for podcasting but they
don't do the basics as well as they
could and I think that's you know that's
the the take-home piece of advice that
I'd give you guys who are developing
these sorts of apps is get the basics
right you know get that that first
screen when I open it up and I just want
to start listening to a podcast make all
of that as simple as clean as easy can
be and then everything else that's all
that's all the bonus that's what makes
you better than
and all the other apps put up the the
angry baby 415 absolutely just say look
these aren't things that we walked in
thinking all podcasts app should do this
is something we wrote this morning after
sitting down with 12 different podcast
apps trying to make them work trying to
make them fit our lifestyle and
ultimately deciding that none of them
were actually what we wanted so make
that podcast app you got Maya dollars
I'll pick you know I would pay 20 bucks
I should point out as well that these
podcast apps at least two or three of
these were paid apps between sort of one
and five bucks and people will pay five
bucks for an app if it does everything
that they wanted to do any day of the
week
absolutely all right so we have to go
get Dan Galpin out of his cage and lay
down the protective sheets along our
camera here to make sure that he doesn't
spin all over it so we've got a lot of
work to do before the Friday review of
games starts so rate oh I think we
should sign off we should thank you very
much for joining us this week
absolutely hopefully we'll see you again
in the future thank you especially to
Fred and Daniel for helping us out
behind the camera we're gonna be back
next week same time one o'clock on
Friday I think we're going to be looking
at finance apps next week is that right
Fred finances I think so so do make sure
that you put your nominations for
Finance apps that you've used and you'd
like us to take a look at in the
moderator page and we will see you again
same time next week thank you for
watching
you